Speaker 1: I want to look at a clip with
you today of this Christian hate preacher,
Greg Locke. Okay. This is a guy we've talked about
before. There is a church called the Global Vision
Bible Church in Tennessee. I looked to see if
they are actually a tax exempt church, and I
was not able to definitively find out one way or
the other. As many of you know, churches, real
churches are able to be tax exempt in the United
States. This allows them to not pay property tax.
This allows them a lot of other tax benefits.
And one of the rules is they're not allowed
to do politics at the pulpit. You can't be a
political organization and have tax exempt status.
I'm going to play a wild clip for you here from
Global Vision Bible Church. This is Greg Locke.
He threatens Democrats that are watching him. He
threatens an insurrection. He says that nobody
in his church should be voting for Democrats.
This is the epitome of why there should not
be tax exempt status for the religious wing of
churches. If you run a school, a church school,
a church based school, and you're teaching real
curriculum. I'm actually okay with the educational
side of a church having tax exemption, but this
sort of stuff has to end. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 6: To the place right now. If
you vote Democrat, I don't even want
you around this church. Get out.
Speaker 1: Okay. So right off the
bat saying Democrats aren't welcome here.
That's a pretty political statement.
Speaker 6: You get out, you Damon,
you get out. You baby butcher an election thief.
Speaker 1: So that, by the way, baby butchering,
that's talking about abortion. So this is all
politics. This is exactly the stuff churches
aren't allowed to do if they want to maintain
tax exempt status. How many billions of dollars
are being subsidized by random taxpayers because
churches don't pay taxes but still do politics?
Speaker 6: You cannot be a Christian and
vote Democrat in this nation. I don't care
that it makes you. You get pissed off as you want
to. You cannot be a Christian and vote Democrat
in this nation. They are God denying demons
that butcher babies and hate this nation.
They hate this nation. Get mad all you want
to. I don't care if you stay in. I don't
care if you throw tomatoes. Praise God. I'm
about to throw a microphone up at his house.
Right. CNN, carry my dirty sock. You
cannot be a Democrat and a Christian.
You can not somebody say amen.
Speaker 1: I actually don't remember.
We once had a video of a pastor that ate dog
poop on stage to prove some kind of point.
I don't remember if it was this guy. Let
me see Greg Locke eating dog poop. Um.
I think it was okay. Let's continue anyway.
Speaker 6: The rest of you. Get out! Get out!
Get out! In the name of Jesus.
Hey, playing your stupid games,
budget devils. I'm sick of it. I
won't talk about the insurrection.
I'll go tell you something. You
ain't seen insurrection yet.
Wow. You keep on pushing our buttons,
you low down. Sorry, compromisers.
You got hate and communist. You'll
find out what insurrection you
cause we ain't playing your garbage We are.
Speaker 1: So now Threatening violence,
threatening something Even saying that the so
called insurrection of January 6th. That ain't
nothin compared to the insurrection they might do.
Speaker 6: Play in your mess. My Bible says that
the charge of the living God is an institution,
that the gates of hell shall not prevail against
it. And the Bible says they we'll take it
back, because that's what the Bible says.
That's what the Bible says.
Speaker 1: Imagine thinking that this nonsense has
anything to do with the teachings of Jesus. Like
I'm not a Christian, so I don't care about the
teachings of Jesus. They have no impact on my
life whatsoever. But I know people who actually
care about the teachings of Jesus in so far as
how to treat other people and feeding the poor
and being a good neighbor and all these different
things. This has nothing to do with the teachings
of Jesus. And the idea that this is a so-called
Christian church is absolutely bonkers. Now,
again, on the tax exempt status. This is Global
Vision Bible Church in Tennessee. There's another
church by a similar name in California, which is
tax exempt. That's not this church. I looked for
the 501c3 status and and number nonprofit number
for this church. I wasn't able to find one. Now,
that doesn't really mean anything very
often these churches, even though it's
called the Global Vision Bible Church, it might in
reality be called something like, you know, one,
two, three, four, five Ministries, LLC, and I just
don't know. So that's a very common thing that the
actual filing name is different than the doing
business ads. But at this point, at minimum,
there should be an investigation due to the
very brazen calls for violence. And number two,
if they are tax exempt, he is literally saying,
Democrats, get out. If you don't allow Democrats
in your church, you're doing politics and
you shouldn't be a tax exempt institution.
Horrifying. And I don't have the number in
front of me, but I've previously told you
billions of dollars a year go
in the form of tax exemptions
to churches, many of which do political ad
advocacy, which they should not be doing